in its most recent statement the FOMC
again noted that it judged it would be
appropriate to raise the target range
for the federal funds rate when it is
seen further improvement in the labor
market and is reasonably confident that
inflation will move back to its two
percent objective over the medium term
the committee will determine the timing
of the initial increase in the federal
funds rate on a meeting by meeting basis
depending on its assessment of realized
and expected progress toward its
objectives of maximum employment and two
percent inflation if the economy evolves
as we expect economic conditions likely
would make it appropriate at some point
this year to raise the federal funds
rate target thereby beginning to
normalize the stance of monetary policy
indeed most participants in June
projected that an increase in the
federal funds target range would likely
become appropriate before year end but
lymph let me emphasize again that these
are projections based on the anticipated
path of the economy not statements of
intent to raise rates at any particular
time